A root of a polynomial is the x coordinate of one of its x-intercepts. We've
been looking at equations for parabolas that can be written in the form y equals
ax squared plus bx plus c. And then we want to find the x intercepts, we replace
y with 0. And come up with a quadratic equation. Any numbers that satisfy this
equation, are roots. Well we've been solving for x using factoring, or the
quadratic formula, or finding the roots of these quadratics. It's convenient to
have the word root, because I've been asking you for x intercept over, and over
again. But for every x intercept, the y value is 0. So just keep in mind that a
Y value that goes along with the root to create the coordinates of a point is 0.
Just like we plugged in here.